[Musique]
à mon arrivée on a parlé de nous ça car
oui oui et non étrange
oui sinon l'europe s'en remet pas et je
mets entre les mains des mélanges r vous
appelez en corse à des mélanges et moi
j'avais appris que ça fait des belles
enchères il ya une quinzaine de jours je
vais à cet examen mais aujourd'hui ce
sont les aubergines alors là je crois
que dans cette recette là il n'est pas
question de la guerre mais bel et bien
de réagir
alors oui nous allons commencer la
recette
ainsi nous allons couper quel rôle vous
dis bien dire
rejoignez employés les morceaux de boue
que les réserves je m'en servais tout à
l'heure c'est tout de même le confort
des romans conduisent au pour qu'elle
soit le plus long procès combien 5 au
berger oui j'en ai un peu plus que ça
parce que j'allais là également dans un
acteur jouer je me servirai également
escaut 3 kg aux trois lions avec la
cause caezar et voilà c'est ça mon jeu
je t'avais guerre économique parfois
beaucoup de points
bon et bien voilà je vais arrêter vous
disais que c'était d'europe centrale la
recette de leur sang vous aller puiser
vous êtes là maintenant on s'est
reconnus d'ailleurs la moussaka la
moussaka est devenue une recette
absolument internationale surtout parce
que les routes classiques
d'ailleurs est ce coffret on parle on
part dans ses livres de cuisine soit il
en parlait en fait ils se croient tout à
fait celle là marin staios ont beaucoup
et je crois que les différentes sortes
de moussaka je dois y avoir une moussaka
juil merci et la moussaka juive doit
être au roulement sans cochon et à son
port et je le crois la danse est là il
ya du porc préférant une raison
d'origine arabe s'embrase s'arrête pas
seulement parce que j'irai à qui ce qui
s'apparente beaucoup à la cuisine
alsacienne et on les confond d'un
certain
là on appelle une carte par l'alsacienne
une cape régie et vice versa exactement
c'est alors le revenant l'auberge et et
où j'allais bien pouvoir neige déjà les
paris légèrement comme ceux-ci chacune
oui on prépare une par une ou dix
parties cela alors qu en afrique par une
installation telle crise ne permettra de
faire trop rapidement ça fait rien voilà
mais tout n'est pas perdu mais dans une
poêle sipa graphique de ce que vous non
je n'avais pas de répéter je les ferai à
la poêle dans l'huile
c'est de l'huile uniquement uniquement
de judo et au aussi avaler parce que ne
s'agit pas que le noircissement plus
lorsqu'elle avait le tort que le puits
d'un tout petit peu sentir pour autant
alors le contenu
quelques-unes comme ça pour remplir ma
foi aujourd'hui je sais pourquoi je suis
une recette vraie grandeur c'est à dire
que vous avez le temps nécessaire pour
la
non je ne pense pas mais j'ai pris mes
précautions c'est bien alors cette
passion soit sa soeur et elle avait
gagné pour cette ce voyage l'assistance
soyez ce mot je m'en vais ici également
paris mais celles ci pendant lequel les
autres joueurs ont travaillé la voix de
recettes aux deux quatre six personnes
environ de plus tôt 6 4 alors ça se
passe très bien on voyait le temps
d'entendre isoler les farines et je vais
les assaisonner légèrement alors un tout
petit peu de sel c'est vraiment la
saison des aubergines c'est pour ça que
vous écoutez le couac il ya une petit
peu la loi des séries dans un peu dans
tout quelques fois on fait deux ou trois
recettes de pâtisserie et unes après les
autres et ce à deux autres légumes et je
n'ai pas voulu et d'ailleurs c'est un
petit peu à la demande des
téléspectateurs je me plie le plus
possible répondant à leurs desiderata
quoi que ce soit pas toujours très
facile en redemande quelquefois de la
tête que j'ai déjà fait il ya deux jours
où peu de temps que je ne peux pas ne
pas les refaire
c'est d'ailleurs c'est assez curieux il
est évident qu'il ya des gens que c'est
tous les jours des propres et par
conséquent je m'excuse en huile et de
regarder ce que je fais malgré le désir
vous auriez vous désirez vous aurez des
spectateurs mais ça n'a rien à faire moi
je suis attiré aussi par votre avaient
parrainé ces où il aurait plus souffert
cette histoire c'est vrai avoue
redemande
des recettes oui le jus baugé randonnée
c'est évident oui je pense que les
téléspectateurs à qui tous les jours des
fois ci devient donc téléspectateurs du
jour au lendemain
et puis il ya tous les émetteurs aux
émetteurs et que si hollande une
nouvelle région mairie
je ne crois pas d'ailleurs qu'il soit
incompatible que je revienne sur des
recettes des cassettes ou trois coups de
jeux qui arrivent on est d'ailleurs pour
le moment c'est tellement vaste le
domaine dans lequel je me promène qu' il
est évident que je n'ai pas besoin de
cela
et si c'est le cas je pourrais illimité
sur une sur une assise non je ne suis
pas sur un terrain aussi un petit peu
mais je ne la trouvera ce n'est pas
utile je vais retirer plus il faut par
quelque chose trop pendant que je vais
préparer la seconde série mais où elles
ne sont pas cuites n'est ce pas elles
sont simplement il se lie alors je
remets le show jeudi vers un deuxième
opération qui va les cueillir
terminez la cuisson et ça c'est pas du
tout parce que je suis pressé c'est
comme ça que ça va peut-être alors voyez
vous je recommence l'opération
donc pas de problème différent mais
ressent avec les courgettes salue on
fait souvent des recettes à base
d'aubergines
non non non il est évident que si on
peut être une recette du même genre avec
des courgettes
ça serait réalisable ce serait pour eux
le vent de très bons ça s'appellera plus
de mousse à tous trois il est évident
que
rien rien à faire à tout cela bon et
bien voilà
la seconde série fois que je vais
acheter un petit peu coopératif je vais
passer une opération tous à savoir
énormément de lui c'est ce que j'allais
vous devez nous allons la retrouver
d'ailleurs en partie hélas elle va une
fois que la recette est cuite lui il
revient à la surface et oblige de la
sorte il ajouté c'est lui qui n'est plus
bonne à rien
en grande partie parce que c'est
ennuyeux c'est gênant est obligé de la
pompe et avec soit avec de la mie de
pain soit faire très attention ne pas en
des moulins de ne pas casser le gâteau
car il s'agit d'un gâteau en réalité la
moussaka fini comme un gâteau en dessous
d'aubergines très spectaculaire très
joli à voir d'ailleurs pas sûr que m non
pas d'une pâtisserie
jusqu'à présent il n'avait pas dit c'est
la composition dans les meilleurs des
cas très nombreuses fois excusez moi que
nous avons espoir que je ne sais même
pas si je ne vous en aurez pas plutôt
deux cas on le voit aller aux mêmes que
maintenant quand j'ai fait mes premiers
j'étais en train d'écrire bon j'ai donné
mon stylo alors je me cherche des xkrs
alors il est où ici c'est pareil dans
les gouttes et ses origines d'ailleurs
ça se voit dans votre ville qui a du sel
vous voyez que c'est pas plutôt la
farine que l'on voit ainsi pas moi je
crois plutôt que fignon
enfin une expertise oui je suis alors et
vous je remets ma poil au chaud j'ajoute
un petit peu d'huile car bien haut
rhinois vous perdiez pas voilà et puis
je vais couper rapidement à ces objets
n'ont pas vraiment comment régulièrement
standard est aussi régulièrement conçus
par d'autres
la recette est bienvenu falloir tout
départ et de viande tout à l'heure en
l'occurrence ce sera du beurre et du
plan ça peut être du veau du port du
coeur ça peut être du mou quand la vraie
recette qu'en fin d'après une des vraies
si je comprends bien ce que fait avec du
mouton pas essayer de vous faire une
passe en boucle messieurs la ferme à
moussac attractive 150 c'est que c'est
un petit peu une recette qui se fait
avec des petits restos je crois même si
même en europe centrale
ça compte ça je crois je suis pas
tellement sûr
bon c'est bien soyez je vais londres
paris nous sommes tout petit peu comme
ça puis les matins ça me brûlait se
forme d'art ce qui est toujours embêtant
ce projet le pic d'amour propre nom
tu vois des petites échelles mais oui je
m'en servirai en son temps voilà le
soleil s'est ouverte et c'est vrai
qu'elle volait tient bon et bien pendant
qu'elle revend cuisse et d'aubergines
car nous allons effectuer un tout petit
peu avant les faits nous allons nous
occuper de ce mot c'est un petit ménage
et je vais aller m'occuper de la viande
non je vais gagner mon alors aussi le
moule
voici mes aux bergers et hoyaux je vais
les rangées comme ceux ci au fond du
moule en limitant en évitant une fleur
entre elias même quels sont les ihm sur
les autres puissent pas aller les voir
tout à l'heure
comme je vais démouler enfin je vais
aimer les unes sur les autres connexions
brochand quelques ça et je me voyais le
remarquer si si si je ne veux pas alors
la dernière et rouge la route sous l'ère
150 pages voilà alors là est ce que l'on
peut voir voilà beau temps mais au
milieu qui fort en quelque sorte une
espèce de marguerite voyez vous pas
marre eh bien je vais tapissé maintenant
tout autour le moule avec d'autres
aubergines commençait alors à plat sur
le port soit pour faire simplement je
vais remettre une erreur
enfin dans un grand hall importe même si
on n'a pas de mal à personne dans une
casserole une petite casserole comme ça
il répond eh bien là je m'en vais avoir
subi hier un niveau suffisamment cru
qu'on avait les versets ici comme ceux
ci est où là heureusement ce n'est pas
partout là elles ne sont pas tout à fait
quick mais ce n'est pas nécessaire à la
corpulence et je l'aimé aussi ici au
fort alors j'aime le moule qui est
préparé et décoré avec des larmes de et
je passe maintenant ma machine à acheter
si vous voulez dire donc que soit
laissée est ici vous allez vous voilà le
buzz et voici le port
alors il s'agit de filet de porc mais
n'importe quel morceau répond contre le
couple entre acheter je m'en vais le
passer à la machine alors vous
connaissez les systèmes n'ont pas prise
au sérieux de celle ci qui est très très
confus tellement peu le sport y
apprendre pourquoi de difficultés à vous
voilà c'est bien ça va être fini qui
sert à faire passer la totalité ce que
l'on met la machine ruraux afin qu'on
peut en talons de pain comme ceci pour
le met dans la machine et se cacher le
passage de la viande il reste dans la
machine et n'être plus que de la vitesse
qui n'a aucune espèce d'importance ce
sens où la vitesse mardi soir là alors
on a chacun notre place respective et
habituel je vais pas d'une personne que
voici
et la mettre au chaud je vais prendre
une petite soit ai je répondu perd un
morceau de verre voilà soit tellement
gros et danseurs
qu'est ce qu'ils aiment faire je vais
faire fondre les échalotes s'est allié
je vais prendre deux cuillérées à soupe
de charlotte voilà et jalouse
voilà et cgc vont dire mes tripes en
quelque sorte n'est pas nécessaire
quelle crise mais c'est bien que l'on
dise simplement puisque je vous dis moi
ton tel être eh bien nous allons les
mêlées tout de suite à la viande peu
voire carrément demandé que les
échalotes ont pris un peu de couleurs
alors nous revenons ici nous donnons un
petit tour comme ceux ci dans le beurre
juste que ça se mélange et que ça soit
saisi hoyau l'audience et un tour de
deux casseroles
voyez-vous et le père sa couleur on
dirait le rosé pour devenir blanche et
voilà c'est fini
c'est tout à fait ça oui voilà ça y est
nous allons saler poivrer
la saison termine bon une série que
voici
nous allons verser dans cette série la
viande qui vient de sortir vous en
sortir de notre ressort viendrez c'est
bien des choses mais ensuite nous allons
prendre avec une cuillère dans une
excuse mais c'est chaud alors je vais
goûter aux aubergines forme que et au
sens du tout pour nous d l'huile est
allé au fond je vais les égoutter les
aubergines qui était voilà c'est ça et
je vais même aller tout ça
voyez on mélange sur wii fait chaud il
fait très chaud
oui on n'a qu'à continuer comme ça voilà
et bien maintenant nous avons mélangé
ses les aurait dû émettre le restaurer
j'oublie toujours par ce petit perçoit
les choses et chaque fois le bruit d'un
tout petit peu oui sans doute déjà vous
avez vous avez vu la dernière fois que
nous avons fait les aubergines qui
étaient cuites à l'eau mais elles ont eu
vite très vite
bon eh bien maintenant nous avons
quelqu'un l'auberge et 10,6 en rondelles
nous avons le moule eh bien nous allons
nous allons faire disparaître ceux ci et
le tamoul et la moussaka nous allons la
moulait avec une cuillère dans ce moule
alors d'une part nous prenons le
mouchard cage de lhenry à l'inversé
comment la faire relativement vous
avancez vous bien là
en ayant soin de ne pas tomber les
petites aubergines que vous avez
installé que j'ai installé d'ailleurs
vous allez voir pourquoi quand nous
allons arriver parce que vous avez
oublié alors de loin de l'arrivée à la
hauteur nous allons remettre une rente
une en remettre à temps des vosges est
pas sacré ne bougeait pas segmenter
mais bien que l'on voit et je voudrais
continuer à miser car ça s'appelle
chemise et chemise et le moule avec des
aubergines comme ceux ci fais ça avec
des gâteaux arrière oui oui bon je
continue un moulin c'était bien je me
disais la viande est alors je dors mal
d'épisodes attend dé voir ses fans tout
à fait unique
après tout il y est incorporé claironné
le monde je sais qu'ils restent alors
nous allons fermer pardon il convient
donc de la même façon que l'on fait tout
à l'heure alors là on peut le voir et on
fait également une sorte de marguerittes
comme ceci autrement dit on avait mis
une couche aujourd'hui bien bien bien
incomplète couche de farce avait remis
chemise et vous voilà maintenant je mets
une dernière ici comme ceci est une au
milieu et j'ai retenu de menveo côté
c'est par ici
oui ça va mal on dirait on le dirait mon
des horizons
alors maintenant que est assez cocasse
aussi avec une écumoire
qu'est ce que vous avez à faire de sa de
cela bien je vais le mettre au four et
au four je vais le cuire pendant une
demi heure
alors je vais aller au four maintenant
mais en réalité tu vas sortir une suite
qui est dédié à la réplique nous
travaillons et qui est par conséquent
depuis une demi heure environ
alors voilà la moussaka la moussaka
moulay nous allons nous pouvait on aussi
ça se fait également lieu de mélanger la
chair des aubergines avec la chaire de
farce à pâté on peut aussi faire des
couches superposées
enfin pas n'importe qui il savait il
prend ça avec un avec attention c'était
pas changé alors voilà qui est jaugé
vous mangez sain changé d'aspect
alors attention à la volée forte alors
que bon et bien avec un couteau je vais
m'assurer qu'elles sont non que second
se détache et à 28 alors est ce que je
vous ai dit la lui il remonte un petit
peu alors je vais essayer d'en experts
une partie de cette paix avec le même
processus que j'ai tout à l'heure tu as
et alors là
alors pour démouler une moussaka ou des
moules ans a exactement comme si nous
voulions tout autre espèce de gâteaux de
préparation dans un plat
voilà comme ceux ci ont été pris on
vient chercher là ici les deux
oreillettes n'est ce pas il retourne on
se rate rien que ce soit au milieu
voilà et en enlève le moule comme ceci
voilà parce que là j'ai toujours un
petit instant dévotion voilà la moussaka
je ne pense pas qu'il y ait d'autres
problèmes pour n'ai pas compris non
c'est d'une grande simplicité ne pouvons
répéter dans essayer de la mettre au
milieu du plat nous allons la parsemer
comme ceux ci de persil haché tout
autour qui donnera tout de même un petit
aspect est lui pèse pour les farines est
passé à lviv légèrement ses idées de
côté à lui également ce qui reste et
goûter également tout ce qui restait
également tout ce qui restait et puis
alors au dernier moment nous avons mis
toute chose au psg nous avons passé à la
machine une farce composé en ce qui
concerne cette moussaka la barrique de
porc et davos de bain de boeuf
nous pourrions mettre vos d'ailleurs m'a
fait ça n'a pas de bordas en réalité la
moussaka se fait très souvent et je vous
le dis et je le répète avec du mouton
mais alors là on peut la faire et ce que
l'on veut et puis on la cuit au four
pendant une demi heure on la démolit est
alors une petite incidence que nous
n'avons pas parlé la moussaka se mange
aussi bien froide que chose mais je
l'admirais tout ça saute par les
méchants et après on a aussi bien fait
ça se sert un début enfin mon dieu c'est
un plat principal en quelque sorte comme
plat de résistance et vous en poisson
mais ça fait à la fois dans le plat de
résistance et légumes ah oui c'est un
plat de résistance
il vous servez ça souvent vous souvent
souvent c'est très bon c'est très
classique aussi c'est très glissant
audit doré bon vous nous avez parlé de
vous en reparlerai parce que je crois
que vous avez une autre recette qui est
en nous sommes dans l'auberge est banal
je pensais que chaque si vous voulez au
nom s'arrêtera deux camps fait brûler
bon ça va être à 2,6 pour cette
magnifique boussac
cette charte et merci
[Musique]